where were you when oculus rift
pre-orders opened up if you were waiting
to buy one online then you were probably
staring at your browser hoping the store
would load if you're waiting for an
official price the reveal should sound
pretty familiar 599 u.s. dollars that's
right an oculus rift will cost you six
hundred bucks the pre-order package
includes the rift sensor remote and an
xbox one controller plus free copies of
V Valkyrie and Lucky's tale there's a
limit of one per customer but units will
begin shipping this spring the bright
side is that you don't actually have to
spend any money to preorder the headset
you will only be charged when your unit
ships this will also give you priority
access to purchase oculus touch
controllers whenever they launch and no
there's no official price point for
those right now either 2016 is shaping
up to be the year of virtual reality you
can take the leap now and get some nice
pre-order bonuses or wait until the
price inevitably goes down though that
may take a long time until then keep it
locked to gamespot for all things VR